-Welcome back to "Late Night."
We're here with Bill Burr.
And now, Bill, with those fo
a discerning ear for dialects,
they might know that you are
from the New England area.
-Is it still that bad?
I feel like
I got a lazy Boston accent
-Now tell me, how do you feel?
Obviously, there was a lot o
New England DNA
on that Tampa Bay team
with Gronkowski, with Tom Brady.
-Antonio Brown.
-Were you happy for them,
or was it heartbreaking?
-Oh, my God.
I was rooting for them
like I was watching a Pats game.
I love all of those guys.
And all of them helped
put the Patriots on the map.
And they are free to do
what they want to do.
And if that's the place
that they want to play,
I'm not gonna be upset about it.
And I wanted to see him --
I wanted to see Brady
get his seventh because,
you know, just during
this whole time of social medi
and everybody just hating on
everybody, I just feel like --
I don't know -- it's kind of
shameless the way people
have behaved during
his incredible career,
both owners of football teams --
the Colts --
right up to, like,
fans and stuff.
And then,
I am a huge football fan.
And I think
if you were a football fan
you actually
enjoyed the game yesterday
But if you're the casual fan
that likes offense,
you probably didn't like it.
But just to watch them
with that game plan,
which I've seen beat a tea
like the Chiefs for 40 years
of watching football,
you take away their number-one
option, establish the run game
time possession,
when you watch a team execute it
the way Tampa did,
it's literally an art form
And I won money on Tampa.
I won money on Cleveland, too,
'cause they had a team
that could've beat them.
They just -- I don't know.
People sort of get enamored by
how quickly K.C. can score
and then they feel like then
they have to go to the air
and you want
to slow the game down.
So I did learn that with -
-You mentioned the Colts.
Is it safe to say that you
still have a bone to pick
with deflategate?
Is that what
we're talking about?
-No, there is no bone to pic
with that.
It's just -- I mean,
it got laughed out of court.
The judge was, like, pisse
for them wasting their time.
So then, they had to come
with this whole other idea
on how to suspend Tom.
Like, "Are we a corporation?
Is he an employee?
Do we have a right
to suspend him?
Then he's suspended."
It was so ridiculous.
And, meanwhile, that guy,
is like --
he tanked Tampa's football
season to get Andrew Luck.
They pumped crowd noise in
He sat on the competition --
I've been through this
a million times.
You can do your homework
or you don't.
But whatever, I get the thing.
So I was psyched
that he was gonna do it
with Tampa,
so maybe people would stop
hating on him.
And then, I don't know, K.C.
has family members
sending out tweets
trashing the refs and stuff.
It's like, don't you think
your team lost their composure
a little bit
somewhere in the second quarter?
I think that's
why Tom was laughing.
I don't know.
-I do.
I do think that deflategat
was -- you know, was silly
I do also, as a Steelers fan
think spygate was real.
But again.
-It was.
It was!
But you know what else was real?
Was the '70s Steelers
all being on steroids,
including the running back
who admitted it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. That's true!
I'm not fighting.
-But that's okay.
That's okay.
But that's okay.
It doesn't count.
-At the time, it was
the moneyball of its era.
-Fran Tarkenton
still bitches about it.
Fran came out on the field
and goes,
"Why are they
so much bigger than we are?"
[ Laughter ]
But listen, that's --
And there's another thing, too
Like, as far as, like,
stealing signs,
if you think that's cheating
then we should forfeit
World War II.
[ Laughter ]
Like, stealing signs is an art
It's not like
you're filming them,
and they're over there going
"Throw the ball to number 10."
[ Laughter ]
It's like, you film them,
and then you go through it
and at halftime,
you can steal one or two signs
And it's not illegal to have
a camera up in the booth,
by the way.
It isn't.
They just don't want you
to have it down on the field
which is why --
I've said this a million times
If you watch
a college football game,
when they're sending in plays,
a guy's holding up a sign.
It's like, a piece of toast,
the sign for pi.
It's like, "Why do you think
they're doing that?"
[ Laughter ]
Okay?
And I'll go even further.
I think the Houston Astros
that was a legit
World Series championship.
-All right.
-If the Red Sox and Yankee
can have $200 million
roided-up free agent teams
and go around the league lik
it's their breakfast buffet,
then why can't
they put up a camera
and bang on a trash can?
Good for them.
They probably -- they finall
brought a gun to a gunfight.
[ Laughter ]
I'm so sick of people acting
like there's a Santa Claus
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, I have one last thin
to ask you about.
-There's all kinds
of stuff going on.
I love a corked bat.
-Yeah.
-I think it's hilarious.
I love when a pitcher's
on the mound,
and he's got half the condiments
from Arby's on his shirt.
I love filming all those guys.
It's hilarious.
[ Laughter ]
And I've actually heard
that a lot of batters
prefer that they do that,
because if they have
more control,
they won't get hit in the head
with a baseball and die.
[ Laughter ]
So it's like, "Yeah, I'll hit --
I'll hit .290
instead of .297 and live."
[ Laughter ]
So, I don't know what people
are whining about.
But he's got seven now.
So I don't know --
I don't know what to tell you.
I mean, if you're still gonn
sit there and whine about it
then God bless you.
But, like, he's now, like --
he has seven.
Bill Belichick has eight.
-Yeah.
-Yogi Berra has 10.
I think Bill Russell has 11.
And at that point,
you have to get into coaches
And it's Phil Jackson,
then Red Auerbach.
It's insane.
-It's a good list.
Last, quick question
I want to ask.
Because you were so good
in "The Mandalorian."
It was such a joy
to see you in that.
Was that something -- did yo
grow up a huge "Star Wars" fan
Because I've talked
to a lot of people
who have had cameos in that show
or parts in that show,
and, for them,
it was a huge deal
to be a part
of the "Star Wars" universe.
Was that true for you?
-No, I was a spaghetti Western
Clint Eastwood,
like "Once Upon a Time
in the West,"
that type of stuff,
although I just saw
that movie for the first time.
But any movies like that.
And when I got into this thing
I thought it was gonna look like
most of the "Star Wars"
things looked.
But when Jon Favreau showed me
what it was gonna look like,
and Rick Famuyiwa,
that I was in, basically,
a spaghetti Western in space
like, I was beyond --
I still can't believe that
I'm a small part of it, man.
It's an amazing --
Like, I don't know why
I've been so lucky in my caree
where I keep falling
into other people's greatness.
You know?
I did, like, three or four
sketches on
"The Chappelle Show,"
I did a couple of episodes
of "Breaking Bad."
I fall into this
"Mandalorian" thing.
I have nothing to do
with any of these things.
[ Laughter ]
They're all other people.
And I somehow, like --
I'm, like, the fan guy who
came down in the boxing ring
So I get to be
a part of these things.
Which takes me back to Patrice
Because Patrice
was that level of a talent
It's "Killing is Easy,"
is the name of the documentary
It comes out February 19th
on Comedy Central.
And there's a lot in that title,
with the depth of Patrice.
Because with most comedians,
it's all about killing,
and that's where you stop.
And that's where he started.
That's how funny he was.
He was like, "Standing up here
and making these people laug
and killing is easy."
He went Colonel Kurtz,
like in "Apocalypse Now."
He went upriver,
he left the program
in the greatest
artistic way ever.
And it was a pleasure
to watch him do it.
And I miss him tremendously.
-Well, I'm so glad you did it.
I can't wait to watch it.
Bill, it is always
a pleasure to see you.
Thanks so much
for making the time.
-No worries.
Thank you so much.
I'm gonna work on my accent.
[ Laughter ]